welcome to the third talk today so today
we are going to talk about functional
prgs so take it away
um yeah hi everyone uh yeah I want to
first thank the organizers for inviting
me and organizing exciting workshops
um yeah so today I'll I'll talk to you
about a line of work that uh
um kind of introduces a new framework
for constructing pseudo-random
generators what which uh you know we
call
through what we call a fractional
pseudorant of generators so my you know
main objective of the talk today is to
introduce
uh to you what fractional super random
generators are and why they're useful
and my second objective is to try not to
fall from this line
um yeah so there is a lot of letters
involved in the works that I will cover
so I'm one of the ages so this is ishan
chatapada hosseini and shakar loves and
follow-up work with
[Music]
and tar
um and there's another follow-up work so
my main focus will be the first original
work but there are some exciting
follow-up Works um that that build on
these Frameworks that I will introduce
so this is by Charter idea Gayton uh lee
Lovett and Shetty
okay so this is the plan of the talk
um so everything is going to be very
Elementary so you won't you will barely
need even stuff you learned in the
boot camp so I will start by giving a
brief introduction to what pseudo random
generators are then I will
uh Define a relaxation of pseudonym
generators which we call fractional
student generators and I will try to
convince you that this is a useful new
definition by showing you how to
construct them
um in some instances you know
under some conditions
and how they can be used to actually
construct prg's uh under some
conditions
so kind of the the general theme is
we're going to start at the in the
Boolean Cube
um and then go beyond Boolean Cube
and then go back
all right so the main objective is to
solve a question in about Boolean
vectors but we will kind of use
non-boolean vectors along the way so the
the type and and feel free to stop me at
any point anything is unclear so I'm
happy to answer
uh so the the main type of questions
that we want to study uh similar to the
last talk is understand
the random distributions
institutions which in High Level so
you're given you know for a class of
tests so you're given a class of
and
you say that a distribution is
pseudorandom for that test for that
class of tests if none of the tests can
distinguish between the uniform
and that distribution right so the tests
uh from uniform
and I you know intentionally gave this
very high level sort of definition so
depending on the type of problems that
you study the tests and what you want to
understand about the super random
distributions are different so if you're
doing additive combinatorics you may
care about the density of arithmetic
progressions or you know gowers
uniformity Norms Etc but for for this
talk we are interested in uh complexity
Theory type problems
um and because of that our tests are
algorithms or things that we can uh
you know solve efficiently so so for for
the purposes of this stock we are going
to think about pseudo-random
distributions that we call prgs so
what's a prg
uh
let's call uh
all right so let me first Define what
our tests are so our tests are going to
be Boolean functions which we think of a
set of functions that are easy to
compute
thank you
questions
and there's a long list of kind of
ways you can you can formalize what easy
to compute means so you can find very
simple things like uh f
as uh
or you know every F is for your
character
or you can make things more interesting
say like log space
computable or just uh you know bounded
depth
and or negation
circuit
and yes you can Define constant with
branching programs or F2 polynomials Etc
right so these are you know some simple
classes of Boolean functions and one
interesting property that one useful
property that they have is there's not
that many of them okay so that's one
thing that's very useful about them
um and once we are given a family of
Boolean functions that are easy uh we
can think of the input as kind of the
random
string of zeros and ones or pluses and
minus ones that the algorithm is given
and you can think of a one as kind of an
X step so these are decision algorithms
so something that's very you know useful
to try to understand is what is the
probability that an algorithm accepts
right so one kind of useful
ask is approximate
expected value
of f for every
F in F right so we are given some
function the family and we would like to
understand what is the probability that
it's one right uh of course if I give
you access to random coin tosses and as
much as you want you can do this very
efficiently by just sampling
um but our goal is to do this
little
or no randomness
they want to come up with kind of a dis
deterministic algorithm that achieves
this or you know an algorithm that uses
very little
so one black box way to try to attempt
to do this is to come up with what we
call a pseudorandom generator for the
whole family right so what's an Epsilon
to the random generator
ERG
uh for a family f is just simply a
distribution
X that takes values in plus minus one to
the n
such that the expected value for every
function in the family
the expected value of f is under the
uniform distribution
is close to the expected value of f
under this distribution
okay so this is our definition of what
we call a pseudorandom generator and you
may object what what what's the
generator this is just the distribution
and you're right so what we why we call
this a pseudoranum generator is that we
would like X to be generated using very
few you know coin tests true coin
classes so um
so you know a good
I would like
X to be the output of
the function that takes
s bits and outputs these n Bits And we
think of G as a function that Maps
okay so we would like to understand
distributions that we can create like
this and some useful usefulness
properties because we want to use it
towards maybe de-randomization or
approximating the probability of
acceptance is that we would like s to be
much smaller than n
and we would like to be able to compute
g into V1 G
is explicit
so if we could
achieve these two things then we can
solve these type of problems okay
foreign
thing here is that we want the same
distribution to work for every function
in the family right so we are kind of
going to say well if f is a ac0 circuit
then this distribution fools any ac03
um and
so if if I kind of
uh not ask for the second property then
to the random generators are usually
easy to construct by just the
probabilistic argument because most of
these things these classes the number of
functions that have this property is so
small that you can do kind of a union
bound over all kind of sparse sets and
PK uniform distribution over that sparse
and so achieving this explicitness is
the the challenge in in kind of pseudo
randomness
um and for many of these many of these
classes we do know how to construct some
quite efficient to the random generators
so for example we know that all kuntas
are
fooled by any independent
distribution and these are we know how
to construct them really well uh by by
exploiting connections with coding
Theory so we know how to achieve this
with which is this is called the seed
length
foreign
and with error zero right so we know how
to construct perfectly K wise
Independence distributions we know how
to construct how to full free characters
by constructing Epsilon small bias
distributions
um and we can do this also of
and for many of other classes that I
mentioned we know how to construct
somewhat good student generators for
example poly logarithmic in an seed
length but we are not able to match what
the you know the random the randomized
construction the non-explicit
constructions give okay
um so for many of these classes so I'm
going to mention some Frameworks that
have been used towards constructing
pseudorandom generators I'll mention two
of them that are kind of related to this
talk so one thing that has has seen a
lot of success is to just use these two
first types of constructions or
combinations of them and show that
that's enough to to fool much more
sophisticated classes of function so uh
show
that simple
combinations
let's say
simple generators
and some maybe noteworthy examples I
almost did it uh are maybe uh so
braverman's result is saying like ac0 is
full
bye
founded
Independence
or we know that uh you know half spaces
are also fooled by bounded Independents
um or so I guess maybe this is River man
this one is in and look at the letters
excuse me
um
this is uh and and another example is
maybe Viola's generators for degree df2
polynomials to show that you know xor
of the independent
um small bias
distributions
tools
degree d
polynomials
yeah
so I guess so something to mention about
these type of results is so here we are
showing that some very simple generators
full some sophisticated classes of
function so here the the you know the
the challenges is in the proofs so these
are not very obvious or simple proofs
but the generators are very simple so
these are very desirable type of results
that you would want to prove another
type of
another framework that
is really related to this talk is the
pseudorandom restrictions framework
which was uh initially uh put forth by
um this is due to itai
and Victor San
um who introduced this this kind of this
framework in order to construct the
random generators for bounded depth
circuits and ever since this method was
introduced it has evolved into more
sophisticated method and it has found a
lot of success in constructing
pseudoranum generators in the recent
years
um so I can tell you a little bit about
how this this works because it's related
to kind of this this stock
suppose we want to construct this
pseudo-random distribution X
that is a length n vector
of
ones and minus ones
um and for a lot of these simple classes
of
Boolean functions for example ac0 you
can keep AC 0 in mind we have really
good random restriction lemmas that
tells us that on if you fix each of the
bits with probability one minus P to 1
or minus one and leave it alive with
probability P then the class simplifies
a lot so in case of ac0 of depth T you
can show that uh if you leave each
variable to be a star with probability
one over poly logarithmic in and then
the resulting function with high
probability is a decision tree of depth
D and we know how to fool such things
using random generators okay
um and so this this framework kind of
says well what if instead of
independently I fix each of these
these bits to a one or minus one or a
star what if I find a way of doing this
sudo randomly and show that uh like
every
all F and F simplify
under
pseudorandom restrictions
okay
um if we can do this then we can repeat
this process so we fix the you know the
the input bit some of them we leave some
of them alive using very few seed length
and then repeat this right so
um
and yeah so so the the you know this has
been used to for example uh to give
pseudonym generators for ac0
um and the what I will talk about today
is kind of related to both of these is
in the sense that we will show how to
use some
simple combination of simple
pseudo-random generators and and what we
will construct is this kind of this
framework that we will introduce will
give us an a new way of the randomizing
random restrictions in a sense okay so
we won't have to kind of look at the
class and prove a pseudorandom
restriction Lemma for the class
okay any questions
okay so so let me tell you about uh so
let's start trying to talk about
fractional trgs
suppose we are given a function in our
family of Boolean functions that we want
to come up with a pseudo random
generator for
uh and it's it's you know usually these
are Boolean functions it's usually
useful to look at the Fourier expansion
of them right and our choice of one and
minus one has been to actually make this
kind of more convenient even right so we
can always write f of x as
empty side
um
run empty
sufficients and by our choice of ones
and minus ones are for you for your
characters or just products
and our definition of a pseudo-random
generator is just any Distribution on
the inputs such that
uh expected value
F under the uniform distribution is
approximately the expected value of f
and the pseudorandom distribution okay
but now if we look at this the free
expansion so the reason that I single
that is if I to the empty is that that
is exactly what we want to approximate
right so this is f out of M2
and now I'm going to do kind of try to
change the game so our goal was to
construct the distribution that takes
values
over the the Boolean Cube and it's a
sparse distribution so basically you can
think of X as being
a uniform distribution over some sparse
subset of the nodes of the Boolean Cube
and maybe a multi-set of the Boolean
cube in a way that F hat of m t is close
to the average of f evaluated on these
points
and in this talk what we will do is we
will try to maybe relax this game and
say what if I allow you to pick points
inside the solid queue okay
X
distributed in the solid
well what does this even mean so we have
a Boolean function you can't uh evaluate
it and you know inside the solid queue
but
there's a hint here right so we can use
this as kind of an extension of f over
the reals and try to evaluate points on
that so someone is giving us a
distribution over minus 1 1 to the n in
the solid cube and
uh so in this talk I will just uh from
this point on I will use f to denote
it's both the Boolean function and its
extension uh so we we will think of f as
a function that Maps
RN to R
and in fact uh we will only be
interested in the solid cube so I will
ignore the inputs that are outside the
solid queue
so is this an easier task does anyone
see
yeah exactly so this is too easy in a
sense so yes it's much easier
zero is equal to a fat of empty in fact
for every Boolean function so you can
fool this you know the class of all
Boolean functions with zero error with
seed length zero okay
um so what I will talk to you about uh
for the rest of the talk is well you
know our goal I mean I'll remind you
that our goal was to still construct
trgs right and kind of this
this trivial fractional prg is not going
to be useful but if you add some extra
assumptions it turns out that you can
use them to actually
to actually construct prgs
and before we do that we will make some
observations about
kind of the meaning of evaluating
uh you know what you know let's try to
understand what this extension of f
looks like so what are its values yeah
in what sense did you mean uh seed
length zero so this is a so you can
define a distribution that just outputs
always the all zero vector
so it doesn't use any Randomness to
produce its output right so because we
just changed the the game and allowed
just um yeah exactly so in a sense our
you know the goal is now to try to
approximate F of zero
and of course we can just pick F of zero
so maybe I will first Define what an
fprg is
let's go on fprg
or F you say X
is an Epsilon fprg for f
if for every f
the F of zero minus expected value of
Zone and as we saw we can construct this
you know with just picking the zero
um but it turns out that we will need
some extra assumptions of like
non-triviality assumptions to for to
make this useful but before we do that
let's try to understand
y f of 0 is a fat of empty and what is
actually f of x for other uh you know
fractional points okay so the first
observation is that if
y
is a product distribution
taking values in the solid cube
expected value of y is some Vector X
which is again a point in the solid cube
so here I'm taking the expectation of a
vector coordinate y so you can just look
at each coordinate and take the expected
value so this is a observation
is that then
expected value of f of
Y is one
yeah exactly it's f of x
or maybe better choice would have been
or case one or
okay
so in fact any point in the Boolean Cube
uh is kind of can be written you know as
a convex combination of a product
distribution over the Boolean Cube
because if I give you any point in -1 1
to the N you can define a product
distribution that is biased according to
Y and takes values in the actual Boolean
Cube so every Point inside the cube is
you know expected value of f over points
in the cube and F of 0 happens to be the
expected value of the uniform
distribution the product distribution
that's defined as uniform
and that is why we got half of 0.
under the uniforms
you think so this observation is true
for everything but you can if I give you
a vector inside the solid cube you can
define
a distribution over the the Boolean Cube
so basically you will have y i is equal
to one with probability
1 plus
lowercase y i over two and minus 1 with
probability otherwise
and this is a distribution over the
actual View
okay so this observation tells us that
this multilinear extension of f
should be bounded right so it's not
going to have is our values it's
actually it has meaning
so any questions
okay
as I said so I'm you know I'm kind of
dragging along and saying
even explaining some really basic things
but everything I'm going to talk about
is very basic
to be able to talk about it
um so
it turns out that if you add kind of two
non-triviality assumptions then fprgs
become useful in order to construct prgs
so two
useful
conditions
which the the first one is kind of the
the main challenge so we say that a
distribution X
uh over the solid cube is Q noticeable
if each of its coordinates has some you
know significant variance so if
for every eye expected value of x i
squared is greater than or equal to Q
so this is a distribution that's far
from the trivial distribution that we
have so it's it's expectations
and everything every actual prg is one
noticeable
and two is we will for technical reasons
we will need some symmetry assumptions
people
but uh XI and
Negative X I are kind of the same
distribution
okay so that's these are the two
assumptions that we won't need and in
the rest of the talk I will show you
that under these usefulness conditions
we can turn fprgs into prgs so this is
what's what I will show
is that if
all right is an fprg
or F we can turn this into another
distribution that is
prg
or F
and we will just lose some parameters so
if the error here
is Epsilon and the seed length
s
and this is Q noticeable
yeah
then we can turn this into an Epsilon Q
to the minus one something like log n
over Epsilon
error
and s q to the minus 1 log n over
Epsilon
C blanks
and we can only do this under one extra
condition so there's a lot of condition
so you can't always turn fractional
charges into prg so this only works if f
is closed under restrictions okay so if
f is
closed
under
restrictions
which is a property that for most
classes that we care about is true so
what it what closeness means is if I fix
some of the input bits to ones and minus
ones you you know this function is still
computable in that same class is there
an example where it says there are some
examples that would be nice to for
example if you're looking at you know
regular branching programs so the one of
the reasons that some of these
constructions for regular branching
programs don't work and we have to
assume permutation branching programs is
that property for example
and another
useful thing about fprgs is that they're
easy to construct
which is what I will probably mostly get
yeah
so um there's a you know at these the
papers that I had listed that I will
talk about come up with different
assumptions under which we can construct
good fprgs but I will only talk about
two of them here so one is you know if
f f simplifies
under
truly random
restrictions
and the other kind of assumption that I
will talk about is if
F has reasonable Fourier tailbounce and
what this means is that if for every f
or every k
we have that the sum of the Fourier
coefficients at level K is bounded
by some something that is much smaller
than n to the K okay so we have you know
roughly n to the k for your coefficients
here and if you know this is much
smaller than just all of them being
close to one right if you can prove such
a Bound for your class of functions then
we we can show that you can get
immediately a fractional prg and in the
first case if you have proved a random
restriction limit like the the one of
Rossman for a zero then you immediately
get a fractional prg out of it so you
don't have to work extra to de-randomize
it like the right direction
so I'll I'll start with yeah do not get
two from one
yeah in a sense yeah so I guess if it
depends on is is the notion of simplify
means that you can fool it or yeah
exactly but in in a sense yeah it's just
going to be easier to maybe warm up here
yeah
is
um
as well
so s is the seed length of the original
fractional prg I guess something that I
I was postponing to to talk about where
these are coming from so the way this
reduction works is by repeatedly
sampling this many independent samples
from the fractional prg so then you get
kind of a multiplicative C so you need
the original Signet time so many times
you sample from it and each of the steps
of this we will Define a random one will
cause another pair of Epsilon so they
add up to that
so this is saying that for every level K
the some of the absolute values of the
three coefficients at level K is at
mostly to the K and we will see why we
need this to be B to the K so it's
convenient to write this in the form of
B to the k
so we've got some examples of functions
with that example yeah so for example
read one's branching programs was one
example for which we we know something
that satisfies this with B being log n
to the width of the branch Improvement
questions
W read once
branching programs satisfy B is long
again
text I'll log in
and an example here to keep in mind is
ac03
foreign
and one disclaimer here is that you know
although this framework is powerful in
general most of these classes that you
get a prg out of it we know better prgs
and because the kind of the the
techniques used are allowed to look into
the class that they want to fool so that
you can add extra trickery to to make
more efficient generators so what's here
what we will use here are just all these
assumptions and nothing more about the
class we just forget about the class you
know when we construct it
any other questions
anywhere else
um so this you know avisha has a nice
paper where he shows connections to
other things like you know
simplifications under random
restrictions imply L1 bounds or you know
L2 bounds exponential L2 tail bounds
also imply imply this this property
right but these are more General because
you have classes like the parity
function that have this property but do
not simplify nor have L2 tailbounce
so there are classes like the read once
branching programs this is the only
property that they have out of the three
properties damage
okay so so let me talk about this uh
simplification on the random
restrictions
okay so let me first Define what a
random restriction is so a random
restriction is just some distribution
overs uh
plus one minus one and
star to the N so it's a distribution
over that and we will be interested in
product distributions that that fix the
probability of star with probability P
so we will think we will Define our
p
I to be
one with probability one minus p over 2
minus one let's roll with you one minus
Q over two
and star with probable teaching so so
this is a product distribution for each
coordinate we put a star with
probability P so if I'm given a function
I can Define what is f
r p of X so what it what this new
restricted function does is for all
coordinates that are not star it will
fix its input to one or minus one for
the Stars it will use x okay so that's
what the restricted F restricted to RP
evaluated at X means so it's still an N
variate function
okay
and a random restriction Lemma looks
like something like this
so suppose
the probability
over RP that this function
is
belongs to some simple class
almost one
okay so with very high probability under
random restriction F simplifies okay so
now you can
Define what what does it mean for f to
be simple for this purp for this talk
you can say maybe it's a just a class
that we know how to fool how we know how
to construct an actual prg in the case
of
ac0 this is that's the decision tree is
therefore by device Independence
okay
um so suppose
X
is
Epsilon
energy
um and as I talked about if you know if
you want to construct a pre-prg for such
a family now you have to try to
de-randomize this that's one approach
right but if you want to construct a
fractional prg it's very simple
does anyone have a guess
so it turns out that P times x is a
fractional prg
so we don't have to do any work we just
multiplied X by P
okay so why is this true
[Music]
for example yes otherwise we're done
yes
thank you
so then we want to show that P times x
otherwise X is
um okay so the way to do this is we will
first try to understand RP composed with
the all zero vector okay so let's see
what is the evaluation of f
so this by our by the first observation
that we had about the multi-linear
extension of F this is nothing but uh
expectation of f
evaluated my RP composed with the
uniform distribution
um and
this is just
let's see
the product distribution so if you see
RP is already setting ones and minus
ones with the same probability so if you
put stars with zero then it's just the
uniform distribution
foreign
for p
composed with x
[Music]
so if I
so first of all these two things are
close under expectation
because we know that for a random
restriction
this restricted function f restricted
under RP is full is is simple so it is
fooled by our distribution so this is
close to this right so I can replace x
with zero with high probability
so here the error that we will get
between these two also depends on the
probability how good is the random
restriction simplification that you have
so it will be Delta plus the error of
the prg
okay
um and this distribution
just simply
PX
but again applying this the
multilinearity observation
I expected value
so it as a maybe I should have
spent more time talking a lot so F so
this is what I really mean so you're
fixing all the
uh the non-star values according to the
restriction and whatever coordinates are
remained as a star then you look up what
is the value of x
so for example if R was already setting
everything to non-stars then it's
ignoring all of its input but if
everything is a star it's just f of x
so this is a you know two line proof
that P times
the pseudo random generator for sample
is actually a super random generator for
f
so if we have a good pseudorandom
generator a good random restriction
Lemma like for the ac0 which has P that
is
roughly log and and one over
login to the D minus one or something
then this is exactly the type of values
p and minus P are the values that are
fractional prg takes so our fractional
prg is also going to be
P Squared noticeable
which in the reduction that I had
highlighted so that will appear so we
will you know and when we construct the
prg this one over
P Squared will appear so the you know
the kind of student the seed length that
you will get is going to be square of
this 1 over square of this which is
square of what is the best known
constructions for ac0 but you will still
get kind of polynomially close to the
best non-constructions
one question
um so let me also tell you about this uh
this Fourier
till bound uh
instructions and one example to to
assume for the second construction is
there are a lot of families of functions
that don't simplify really under random
restrictions for example one good
example to think of is maybe with two
branching programs that just remains a
general with two branching program on
whatever variables are alive
um
but for for this type of functions we
have a lot of good information about
their Fourier coefficients right
um
and and and because of that it's it's
kind of more useful to try to also
construct fractional Pages here so
here's
the second observation that I want to
make is
that if
foreign
we have this L1 bound
X over 2B
is
on F
prg or
f
X is just simply
and Epsilon small biased
it turns out that just pick a small
biased distribution divide all of its
coordinates by 2B and then that will be
a fraction of prg for for your family or
functions
and here the definition of an Epsilon
small bias distribution is any
distribution that folds all the Fourier
characters right you know all the
characters are have biased at more steps
you know under this distribution
but again it's a very simple
Construction
and you can see that here the this
fractional prg is 1 over 2B squared
noticeable
[Music]
now let's try to understand the expected
value of f under this
alleged
fprg for for our account
so we have X over 2B so this is a going
to be even simpler I won't have to talk
about random restrictions
so what is the value of f on X over 2B
we can just simply look at the expansion
of that
zero
Plus
s
the product of x i over 2B all right
each of the coordinates is x i over 2B
so we just product look at the
characters evaluated on that so then
this is simply expected value of this is
f hat of zero
plus the sum of f of s divided by 2B
the K times the product
there's an expected value
support
foreign
so are there any questions so this is
just a calculation of what is the
expected value of this F extension of it
evaluator and this fractional prg so
this distribution is a fraction of prg
if this is close to expected value of f
which is this so their difference
minus effect of Zero by the triangle
inequality is just simply
the sum over s
divided by 2B to the size of s or this
is sizes
expected value of productivity size
minus
[Music]
to triangle inequality and now our
choice was that X is an Epsilon small
biased distribution so these are all at
most Epsilon
and we know that if you look at this sum
so this is at most
Epsilon times the sum
and this sum you can Bunch them together
based on the size of s and use the fact
that the level K coefficients is at most
B to the K so you get a geometric sum
which is bounded by one so this is just
atmospheres
so the fractional prgs I think the
message here out of these two
observations is very easy to construct
if you already have a random restriction
or bounds on the three of tails and the
follow-up Works uh
have shown that you can do a more
complicated sophisticated argument and
construct fractional prgs out of even
weaker assumptions on the free account
so you can actually construct
um so in in
a joint work
yeah I believe
is where we showed that if you have a
bound only on the second level
coefficients
then we can construct the fraction of
TRG so the issue is that in this case
the kind of
how
the noticeability and the error Etc is
going to be worse so like the the prgs
that you will get out of using these is
going to be have have worse dependence
on Epsilon okay and in fact the the the
follow-up work
the many letters
yes
um showed that
you can kind of improve these and
construct them from even bounds on
things where you bring the absolute
value outside so the supremum of
if you have a bound of the form P to the
K but only for one level
right and the remarkable thing from this
beautiful follow-up work is that they
can get a fractional prg where it allows
these cancellations between the Fourier
coefficients so you can see that the
absolute value is not around the for
your coefficients anymore okay and they
they can do this using you know
connections to approximation Theory by
polynomials Etc
and
uh I guess my summary is that very few
families we know have this that we don't
know how to construct better prgs but
there are families like F2 polynomials
that we hope to prove this hoping to get
prgs for ac0 with parity things that we
don't know right so there are
conjectures that if you can prove
we believe that something like this is
true with polynomial in the F2 degree of
a polynomial and if you could do that
then that would be a breakthrough result
because then you could construct prgs
for degree log n polynomials for example
which is something that we don't know
but another disclaimer is that there are
connections to hard lower bound
implications that this would have like
proving these kind of you know
correlation but you know these Fourier
tail bonds has connections to proving
you know some new correlation bounds
that we don't know how to prove for F2
polynomials
so I'm in a very close to running out of
time so I'm going to tell you uh how to
turn a fractional prg into a prg so the
hint is the the picture of the workshop
very perfectly summarizes it so you want
you will Define a random walk that's
from the center of the key so that's
the idea so I'll just give you a high
level
so that I have a cube here so if you can
see we
um
our goal is to come up with the
distribution over the points of the
Boolean Cube but we are starting with
some distribution let's say that takes P
or minus P values
let's simplify the assumption that this
takes any values right so it's a
noticeable distribution so what we will
do is we will keep taking new samples
from this distribution we start at the
center which is where we want what we
want to approximate and we keep taking
steps according to these new samples
from the distribution and we hope to
take a walk that uh gets very quickly
gets close to the points of the the
Boolean Cube okay and the way to do this
is well you can't just always just pick
X
so if you're you pick your first so
let's say why is your
fdrg
uh you can pick your x0 to be zero to
the end and you can see very naturally
that it's uh the natural first step is
to just go from this to a sample from y
okay but then you can't continue this y
this walk by maybe saying X2 is also y1
plus Y2 because if you keep doing this
you're going to actually jump out of the
cube and keep getting farther and
farther away but it turns out that if
you just normalize this by how far you
are from
the boundary
so it means you know after the first
step
if I'm kind of close
to
to this boundary to this face then I'm
going to adjust normalize
uh you know the make the cube that I'm
taking the new Step smaller and smaller
and it turns
[Music]
we do it coordinate wise so this is yeah
so for each coordinate we will just see
how far we are from one or minus one on
that coordinate and normalize
exactly so this is a yeah wonky kind of
cube after a few steps but the the point
is that you know if we made progress
towards somewhere then the next step we
are more likely to get closer to being
towards that that sign and it turns out
that this intuition actually works out
with a simple you know uh Markov chain
type
the Markov inequality you know
application so it's it's very different
uh so it turns out that you can you can
look at something like each coordinate
and show that after only login over
Epsilon steps with high probability each
coordinate will be within Epsilon over
log n of being one or minus one
and then you can just do a union bound
because the the probability of getting
close is so so high that you can do a
union Bond and just say that after a few
steps we are going to be
very close to one point on all
coordinates being close to one or minus
one and at that point we just round
you just do this for t-steps and output
sine of x t yeah
okay where T is roughly
and over Epsilon over Q
where Q is the note to support
so I mean I am uh out of time but I'm
happy to explain this random walk or you
know why it converges offline
and I also want to advertise to a survey
I wrote with William where
we discuss all these you know different
methods of constructing unconditional
random generators where maybe as a bonus
we also show that you can slightly
improve the dependence on absolute so
you don't have to do this walk all the
way
for all of this many steps you know but
you just you know we shave off one log
one over Epsilon
sorry
also instead of getting something like s
times uh one over p
log n over Epsilon so we kind of bring
this log n over Epsilon to S Plus login
so this is one annoying part that's you
know a lot of this I tie victorson
Frameworks didn't have this extra log
one over Epsilon so you can do it
yeah so you stop when most of the
coordinates have polarized and then you
do something else to sample from a
distribution that's close to being
all one minus one
it's not very significant it's just
not
so
I think also yeah what's your feeling
for the outlook on the F2 polynomial
thing like this this uh cgls that makes
things easier
okay yeah I guess I I should have uh
advertised this a little bit more so the
results of cgls one interesting thing
that it is is that even with the current
bounds that we know how to for for F2
polynomials they're able to almost match
Viola's seed length right it's a
generator because you can apply it for I
mean
almost better but I think you can apply
it for something like K that is log n or
something like that right yeah yeah
um yeah so it's because they yeah so
they can apply this for just one level
right you don't have to have the Bound
for every K which decays
yeah I mean I hope what some of you will
one of you will prove this nice bounds
for F2 Pokemon what we know is something
like exponential with d which is
the other multiple samples of the
instructional generator and then if it
goes beyond one or minus one just throw
plate one or the reasons why you should
do this
I I don't know it maybe it could work
this is just the way we managed to to
make it work better so one one thing
that this makes this is convenient is
you can kind of think of The Next Step
uh the center of the next step is the
convex combination of f on like random
kind of under some random restrictions
right if you're at X you can think of f
of x as like a F evaluated under some
kind of X biased random restriction so
that's how you show that The Next Step
has an expectation close to the previous
step
so each step doesn't also cause much
more error so what you're saying would
also work because then that actually
would be simpler but I don't know
how this like stopping
like how can you get a Boolean value
isn't it hard I mean it's maybe hard to
get any understanding of this
multi-linear extension on any points
outside
yeah so that's a very interesting
question so I think so after here we
didn't use much about the class so it's
very reasonable to expect for specific
families of functions you can maybe stop
this process much earlier so when maybe
a good fraction of the points have
polarized or is like the distance if
yeah there's some smoothness property in
something
we can do this
I guess this this follow-up worker not
just like a shrunk version of
a an action so the question is are there
um fractional prgs that aren't just like
take another simple prg and multiply it
by just some number which I think that
that's what's
like
actually even the the follow-up looks
like this right so it's an x divided by
yeah yeah yeah I think yeah everything
that actually yeah sorry to disappoint
yeah which is I mean maybe it's a good
thing about the ones we know but uh you
know like we haven't found creative you
know much more creative ways to use this
yeah uh I think this this follow-up
worked the way that it works is try to
bound the tail so that all the larger
coefficients you separate them and found
it uh it's value restricted to something
like minus CNC to the N Cube it C is
away from different one and then you
fold the lower section by just maybe K
wise Independence or something
yeah
I don't know okay
no we had enough questions for this talk
so let's take any further questions
offline but let's think for you again
[Applause]